all right
uh so let's get started i also welcome
to mdc
um thanks to organizers for organizing
such a nice event
all right even if it is remote it's kind
of a bummer uh thanks in advance to my
family for keeping in-house intact for
the next hour
and welcome to my talk um refactoring
the architectural
so a little bit about me i'm way lesser
known headspringer than
some dude that's going to speak later
today i have title of principle
consultant
i have been involved in lots of
distributed systems and micro services
projects over the last few years
i've worked on a variety of different
projects and different
kind of sec finance sectors um marketing
sectors different
kind of sectors of um you know companies
and i blog at arade.com
my twitter handle is why are they um
and that's the best way to reach out me
but the other social media handles are
also there
so this talk was really originated from
my experience
of converting monolithic assistance to
microservices project i worked on this
system for
um on this project for more than two and
a half years
um and we came into this project as
consultants
and started looking at this monolithic
architecture here
uh it was a lot it consisted of large
horizontal layers
there were 55 deaf teams trying to make
changes to this application there were
140 art projects
whenever you try to open the visual
studio with resharper on
or any other extensions similar to that
on uh it were crash visual studio
uh it was lots of uh there were frequent
rollbacks of the releases
uh so there was a lot of chaos going on
in that one solution
with all these projects that were
happening um as jimmy puts it here uh
what
monolithic monolith is is multiple
domains
um and multiple domain concerns
and interfaces are kind of mashed into
one x one single application in one data
model
yeah that makes sense but then it more
felt like a dumpster fire when you're
trying to make a change to it when
you're trying to update it
uh it worked don't i'm not trying to
um this at it per se but um
it worked in past uh the however the
current state was sustained on
state that we walked into was
unsustainable
so then we started doing the analysis
and they
we followed this process roughly where
um we started analyzing the domain what
the domain
of the client was uh how their
application worked the business side of
it
and then started defining the bounded
context
uh start figuring out the aggregates
out of that and then eventually start
coming up with microservices
um around that around that around their
business domain
um so then based on that we
put out one microservice into production
and
life was great everything was fantastic
everything worked smoothly
out of that we were able to extract out
the extract out the code from the giant
monolithic application that we had
everything was fantastic but then with
little that we knew
um while our core team was shipping out
that one service
everybody else was doing the same based
on the draft that we created for our
business boundaries
and everybody started pushing out and
working on these micro services the
transformation
the spawn of microservices was kicking
in
and we just didn't know that was
happening so
the dumpster fire that we came from
became more of like a floating duster
fire now
because everybody's trying to make
changes and it
started getting really complicated uh
there was no method to the madness of
any kind so
to keep that in check the architecture
group was formed
and the idea behind that was to rein in
the madness um
it's very hard to disagree with the
initial goal here
uh we want to make sure we wanted to
make sure that we're doing the right
thing
um we wanted to achieve uh we want to we
wanted to help
teams achieve their goal of bringing
uniformity and then they brought us into
uh this team as well who as
microservices consultants
but instead of uh started seeing
improvements right away we started
running into more problems
and some symptoms started to emerge
um so what are the things that we
run into more frequently was the
friction with the agile scrum masters
so whenever we say architecture agile
folks hear waterfall
and that that made all of our meetings
contentious
they were like we lost your hello the
whole thing felt forced
and we started hearing things like oh
we're doing such an
xyz thing because architecture is
telling us to do these things
and that's not what we wanted we wanted
teams to really come to
a solid um solution uh as as a team
instead of saying oh one person or the
other person or some
pilot there is saying something to do
certain way
and that's why we're doing it so all of
this
started resulting into negative
productivity
uh everybody was always behind um
everybody was always catching up from
architecture side of things because
there were so many things happening all
over the place
many different initiatives we're trying
to go to cloud at the same time
we're trying to create platforms tools
patterns all these things
so it was a lot of scattered brain
problems going on we were always busy
but the productivity was not was not
quite there
as a team we also saw that there was
um lack of clarity in the mission like
what are we trying to do
there was confusion about the role
there's not a lot of accountability what
are we supposed to do are we part of the
team are we
are we tech leads to the team are we
tech leads of the tech leads
uh what is going on with our um our
approach
and then as a result
um everybody on the architecture team
felt burnt out we were having business
business issues um
there was a question yeah the in the
slack channel there was a question
um that yeah the the presentation will
be shared so
uh don't yeah so the result
uh of the the whole thing was that we
were feeling burnt out and then the
business impact was not there for our
um for our um
the the architect's architecture team's
goal um the inefficiencies were all over
the place and then the team was
very ineffective and and that floating
dumpster fire really continued
and as as good good consultant we
started to
analyze and say okay let's take a step
back in it and understand what's going
on
um we wanted to establish why this
architecture
or why why do we exist we wanted to
establish that because
we wanted to make sure that teams
understand why architecture is important
and why this team exists so
every every project that you do every
software project that you have has an
architecture whether you like it or not
it it will eventually choose you
so instead of that happening what we
wanted was
intentional direction for our systems
so that we can have architect
architecture of our choice instead of
something accidentally that we're
landing on
um and
then we wanted to also make sure that
we're making decisions uh that are going
to save us money and not
um not not having to
make expensive mistakes and then roll
them back and also wanted to give a lot
of
decent context for onboarding new
engineers because if we give
a feature to develop to a new engineer
and they don't have any context
of why are we doing this uh what are the
architectural design concepts behind
certain things
it gets really difficult for people to
wrap their mind around and
it takes time for them to ramp up so we
wanted to cut that time down
so these books helped me a lot
when i was doing the analysis the
evolutionary architecture
term first came to um
into my vocabulary from building
microservices book
and then other books followed with that
and then greg
gregor hoffa's book he has written
multiple books um
over the years and this is one of my
favorite books that he has written 37
things one architect knows about id
transformation
so that helped me a lot in doing this
analysis
so when we did this analysis we decided
to put this analysis
into some kind of context that people
could understand and
what could be better than having taking
the ideas from martin fowler and then
thinking about smells and refactorings
because as engineers we know what's what
the smells are and
what refactorings are these smells are
essentially just
those subtle inefficiencies in your code
that makes things
really annoying to change and then
refactoring is that we're not redoing
the whole thing we're not rewriting the
application we're
changing the application code
incrementally so that we are
um we are we are making progress
uh but we are not throwing everything
out and then bringing the new things in
so from that perspective uh let's start
looking at
what the smells and refactorings that we
we came up with
based on the analysis that we did first
and foremost there was confusion
about the term architecture itself um
what is what is the architecture um is
it pie in the sky
are we just writing a bunch of documents
are we doing something up front
uh that's gonna spend like two months on
something we're gonna just draw pretty
pictures or something
that um these people over there in ivory
tower sit in there and they troll
and do things what is architecture we
wanted to
understand that and then there was a lot
of confusion across the organization
about
architecture itself there was a lot of
fear fear
uncertainty and doubt um
so the the the most concise definition
and most understandable definition out
there is from martin fowler
which is shared understanding of the
system what is it that your team
collectively understands uh so this is a
really good definition that
resonated with most of us and this
second definition
i personally like a lot uh that i read
from
um that i got from gregor hoffa's book
when the original authors are at the
bottom
uh the design decisions that really stop
you from
exercising needless creativity when
you're trying to solve a problem
so you have a framework in place um to
solve your problems so that you don't
have to figure out
oh what do i do if i have a database
i have a database to choose from and
then i have to make certain query
certain way
uh what is the pattern all of these
things when we're in the middle of the
projects
i don't um we don't want to exercise
creativity at that point
we want to concentrate on solving a
business problem instead of
uh stumbling on these technical issues
as we're going forward
so design decisions are
those are the design decisions make the
architecture and that's kind of started
resonating
with us later on as well but this was my
favorite definition
from architecture standpoint so we
started establishing that okay this is
in our organization this is what we want
to promote
architecture is really what makes your
system easier to change
uh so if we're producing a change uh if
you're if you're trying to change our
application how easy it is
to uh make that change and also we want
to keep an eye on
dollar amount that we're spending uh to
make these
uh changes because if we put an
application into ec2 let's say in aws
or something like that that's not going
to scale very well or
um if we have a monolithic application
that's that that we're just going to
lift and shift into vm or in azure or
anywhere um
that's not the most uh efficient way of
doing things we want to make sure that
we're keeping an eye on how we're
spending our dollar amount
um when we're we're making certain
technology choices the technology choice
could be your database choice whatever
it is we want to make sure that we are
keeping an eye on dollar amount not
saying that that should lead your
architecture
but we want to make sure that we are not
creating waste from
um spending side of things when we're
trying to make these changes into our
system
and we're concentrating on the important
parts of the systems
uh if you have a simple cloud
application
at that point what is the that what is
it that's super important that you wanna
you wanna tell to a person who doesn't
know anything about your system and we
started kind of
uh coalescing around this definition of
architecture
and then we we started um
to partner with agile folks as well and
what we started out with was
agile and agile has its place and
architecture has this place as well
so agile is about efficiency how to
deliver
your features as quickly as possible to
production
and architecture is about effectiveness
are you doing the right thing
are we going in the right direction so
for example i'm right now in
austin texas if i have to fly to
um flight to fly to oslo then
i would have to go east and that's what
architecture is telling me
and the map is a certain path that i
have to fire or atlantic to get to
oslo and that's what the kind of
architecture is about
and efficiency is how do i get to oslo
am i taking a ship
am i flying or or things of that nature
whatever is the most efficient
way of getting to oslo uh is about
is is what agile is and we started kind
of like developing this understanding
yes we both have places in the software
teams
and agile is about efficiency and
architectures about effectiveness the
directional effectiveness
the refactoring then that we applied is
of course promote the definition
around easy ease of change um the
important aspects of the systems and
then
how how we can concentrate on the devops
side of things
and then working with pms very closely
and repeat the message as much as
possible
so that anyone in the organization uh
can easily speak to it
because we had issues where people were
confused about this so
you put out newsletters you put out
different
screencasts whatever it could be um so
that we know that oh this is what the
architecture is all about uh so the
people know that we're not trying to
just disrupt and troll their systems
uh we're trying to actually help and
deliver their software as quickly as
possible and also make sure that it fits
in the larger scheme of things
so this was so architecture is about
what makes
the it's all about easy um how to how to
make your
how to push your changes easily to
production
what makes change so that sounds great
but then what are some examples
of making change easier to your system
so one of the examples here that
of course this is not a laundry list of
everything that's possible
but some of them some of my favorite
things here are event-based systems
so when you have systems that are
communicating with each other
or events you can always take any system
down and
and not have not affect the other
systems um because all the requests that
are coming in or all the processing that
you have to do that can be queued
or put it onto the stream things like
that
so that you can process those as as
needed
vertical slices jimmy bogart has a
fantastic
um talk and blog posts on around this
that also kind of keeps the code nicely
organized in vertical slices that you
can make changes to
and really the robust devops pipelines
so what that means is
if we are confident in our devops
strategies
if we know that we can we believe in
infrastructure as code practices such as
infrastructures code
we have proper monitoring in place we
have
decent deployment methodologies such as
canary
or blue green or whatever that suits
your service
when we have something resilient uh
devops
resiliency around devops in place um at
that point we are confident that we can
deploy our system at any time even if it
is on friday
at five o'clock we can deploy our system
and something
is off like we can always take it back
and when we have this kind of confidence
in our system
everything becomes easier to change and
that's the these are the
these are the kinds of things that we
started looking at uh when we started
thinking about what makes your systems
easier to change
the next smell that we found was uh
about documentation
um documentation sometimes gets better
up like what are we trying to do when we
say documentation are we sitting here
first up and
are writing everything about our service
and saying oh i need to
create all the all this manual about my
service and
how to do these things and all that um
and push it out
is it going to be just one of text no
illustrations we see we started seeing a
lot of these kind of documentation
um so we said okay we we need
documentation but don't spend too much
time
up front creating this documentation uh
you
it's always helpful to have these and
then um
we need we we need to also think about
uh what
what the documentation's gonna have
are we going to have too much too much
text in one
things like that there was a lot of
confusion about what what effective
documentation is um and we started
looking at that so first up we start we
started saying
we need to have diagrams in our picture
so if you look at this diagram
uh it works it make it serve the purpose
for the asp.net team at the time or
net team or microsoft teams over there
um it makes sense
from their perspective but then
sometimes people they take this kind of
diagram a little too far
and think that oh i can lay down my
horizontal layers just like that
and then it will make sense to somebody
but what that is
is that those layers are there but then
i don't know what the relationship
between those layers are so what even if
it worked for that team doesn't mean
it's going to work for your team
from architecture standpoint so this
kind of a diagram is not very useful
it's like saying i need to make penal
vodka
and okay these are ingredients and
that's my architecture for my dinner
is that is that useful and what am i
going to do here
am i dipping pasta into smart enough
marker or am i just drinking vodka i
might just do that
after my talk but that's the that's the
kind of a thing
where um here i don't know what the
relationship of all these ingredients
are
so we need that let's look into this
fantastic example that microsoft has
from microservices standpoint
it is very nicely architected it has
lots of good pieces
involved um it has client apps xamarin
apps
web apps uh it the back end is in docker
um it isn't it has mvc at the time
um it had api gateways all kinds of
technologies are
going on in in this diagram but there's
just a lot of detail in here
it makes it looks great but then if
you ask me five minutes later just
recreate this
i'll be really confused and i'll
probably stop at like second box or
something like that
so it makes sense it looks great but
then it's very hard to
keep it in your mind so how can you
refactor this picture
so at that point i've just taken out the
important aspects of the picture that we
just saw earlier
and then just create an abstraction on
top of that saying you know
i have a bunch of friend in clients
whatever they could be
the pattern is that they're going to
talk to a bff which is
backend for finance api and that's going
to then
talk to the services behind the scenes
or with grpc or http
and then those services are going to
talk to each other uh via events
or some kind of a logical transport and
then
if we have to go into the details of
these these services you can have a
different picture
you don't have to jam everything in into
one picture
and then um the the kind of
value of that diagram is lost so from
that perspective you can always create
your
from individual services standpoint or
different different diagrams
if we need to and then depict what we
need to show from that
services standpoint in here the ordering
service is talking to sql
um sql database and then it's generating
events
um as we see as
it's it wants to talk to the other
services
um outside of its own boundary so
um the picture on the left-hand side
even though it is not incorrect
uh it's not very efficient from me to
remember
either the picture on the right hand
side not saying that's the that's the
way to go about it
but that's one way of refactoring that
picture so that i can just quickly draw
it
onto piece of paper and if somebody
asked me
and then explain them what that system
does
so with this documentation that with
this in mind
the refactoring that we applied is that
we want to have
diagrams in our documentation and you
can
so the reason behind that is uh even if
you have the greatest documentation you
can't force anyone to read those
and so at a glance we want to make sure
that people get the idea of your system
um and then that really helps from
asynchronous communication standpoint
uh we are emphasizing on important
aspect of the system instead of
throwing everything into that one
picture um
and then using known conventions if you
and then creating different views as
well
so you don't have to jam in the
performance views the sequence diagrams
and flow charts and whatnot and
everything into one
because at that point the diagram starts
becoming something that nobody likes
or nobody understands so instead we can
create different views as needed
and don't spend this time upfront we can
always
build this over time and create
these different views use known
conventions that everybody understands
uml
for example if that's what your team's
comfortable with but under
having these pictures into your
documentation is essential so that
people can understand
without reading the entire description
um
what what your system is trying to do
so a book that helped me a lot and i
really liked
the ideas that are in this book at the
back of napkin highly recommend it
um take a look at it excellent resource
the tools that i like are are
the my the most favorite tool here that
i've used in
over the past couple of years it used to
be called real-time board now it's
rebranded as mirror board
uh which is on the left side side the
the best part about that
is working with multiple
team members at a time is really good um
with that tool
and then there are a couple of other
tools that i've used in the past as well
diagram's not made and
lucidchart but again choose the tool
that you like
and make sure that you have good
pictures
in your document in your documentation
so that was about documentation
then the third thing that we started
seeing was people
were too happy and then when they were
trying to
jump onto problems and then they were
too happy to jump on the solutions
because instead of understanding what
the problem is
oh you know i heard microservices talk
um
i saw a container i saw how to set up
kubernetes that's something i learned
yesterday
everything has to be in cloud and
serverless and whatever
and then all these buzzwords that are
happening what happens then is that
we start losing the sight of what
problem we're trying to solve
um so it early in my career i struggle
with this as well
um so i have to be really conscious
about if i
and asked myself and catch myself if i'm
trying to do this
that hey am i solving am i jumping too
ahead of myself am i putting
the card before the horse and
understanding
or if i if i have good understanding of
my problem
so then the typical things that that
that kind of contribute to premature
solutioning
of the problems is that continuously
working in synchronous fashion we'll
look into how to
address those issues later uh but when
we're constantly asked to
come together into meetings and
workshops and whatever and
at that point you're constantly working
in a synchronous fashion um you're kind
of like under the gun to
come up with something and then at that
point you just throw a solution at it
because
in the end uh you kind of like start
getting fed up of these meetings
and you say okay let's let's let's let's
let's have micro services and be done
with these meetings
uh lack of observability is one of the
biggest things
sometimes people say their system's slow
but then they don't
they don't have a clear data behind that
saying why their system's slow what that
means
are you talking about latency issues
what is the latency that is acceptable
are we so
are we solving every latency problem
that's out there or
um how are we trying to wrap our mind
around
what our system performance matrix are
so that's what the observability is and
if when you don't have that
you don't have clean clear enough data
at that point it becomes very difficult
to justify
micro services kind of a transformation
um
because we we don't have any kind of a
concrete aim to hit that
so we don't know if we're making
progress or we're regressing so that
kind of a thing
is a is is really important we um we
started seeing that
when people start jumping onto solutions
um without really understanding the
problem that's one of the things
that's that that's out there that they
don't have clean monitoring solutions in
place
um and then lack of homework and
research is another thing
uh that you want to keep keep yourself
prepared when you whenever you're just
looking into a certain aspects of the
system you want to make sure that you're
studying around it
and complete not coming into the problem
completely cold
because at that point you just want to
at that point you kind of hurry into
something
without understanding what the actual
problem was
so the refactoring really was as you can
imagine
pretty straightforward concentrate on
the what
of the problem really established strong
definition of the what
we're trying to solve because not all
the time you have to solve the most
difficult
problem uh if you can avoid it good
at that point you don't have to worry
about that particular thing and how
we'll usually follow so once you know
absolutely
clearly that this is what i want to
solve um then how
becomes very easy to answer and if
there's up there are problems
uh in that in that's in that's in that
space then you can always
go and investigate how to find um some
material around that and um push that
forward
a test human development approach kind
of helps from this regard
where if we can write tests about
certain problems then i know
what my problem is not saying that
that's the way of doing development
not every possib every every
problem that we have in software
engineering world can be fit into
the corners or four corners of test
driven development
but that's something that i see as kind
of like a guiding principle
from when when it comes to establishing
what i'm trying to solve
if i can write tests that means i can
build it
and then you can add details when it
comes close to the execution time
next up is architecture vision um if you
if you keep addressing the symptoms um
then
it feels like what this cat must be
feeling right now it's trying to solve a
bunch of problems
um but then it's mostly addressing the
symptoms and then
the progress is not really happening so
from that standpoint
let's let's look at an example of what
that what that looks like
so like it look we talked about earlier
when somebody says my system's slow
and the underlying problem could be that
they're making some
um synchronous calls to other services
and the data that that data doesn't
change very often
this is a very real scenario that
happened in our system
so if the patching symptoms um
that we if we were if we were looking at
then what that looks like
is we're trying to make the synchronous
synchronous calls faster and more
reliable
even the reliability is a good thing but
then trying to address
the synchronous call feature may not be
the right thing to do
we need to take a step back and think
about like do we need to make that
synchronous call
uh why do i need to make that
synchronous call do i have incorrect
service boundaries because
usually if you have to um make a call
into other service to do your operation
you typically tend to have a service
boundary problem
and then if if that's not the case then
um how often that data change so
whenever that data change can they just
generate an event
then i can just subscribe to that and
then i have to reach out into that other
system
constantly to to
solve my solve my issues or
perform my operation so at that point
we're really thinking from
problem perspective the root problem
perspective instead of just patting
band-aids all over the place saying oh
just make these synchronous calls faster
um and then that tends to happen um in
in your sprint work and whatever you're
trying to do at that point
oh it's it's very easy to get just make
this call faster it's all good
but then that's where architecture can
help
saying yes you can't do that however you
won't need to think about the root
problems otherwise you'll keep coming
back to it over and over again
so where do we involve architecture in
this whole process
so there is something that we tend to
have
and typically into the workflows
of the teams which is reviewing um
having architecture reviews and at that
point
that is very kind of like a dreaded
thing when somebody says when somebody
uses the word review
um it could become like oh anxious time
um you know it's it's not it could lead
to design by committee meetings are we
just going to
troll each other what's going to happen
in these meetings so that brings us to
the smell that we saw was
about the architecture reviews these
reviews were not very
useful um the refactoring that we
applied
at that point was we need to take us we
need to take
a little bit of a peer approach than
saying architecture is something
you know somebody some people that are
sitting in ivory tower
and trying to make you know trying to
tell you what the right thing is and
you don't know what that is instead
let's make that as a two-way process
uh we wanted to make that a little bit
more scientific
and i'll get get back to the strong
opinions weekly held later on
um but we wanted to make sure that we're
bringing in the opinions
but then when the data that comes up uh
we are willing to
change based on the data that's in front
of us
so we wanted to be so that's the kind of
real process
that we wanted to have and kind of be
empathetic to people's needs and their
deadlines because once you come in and
say
no i want you to do certain things
certain way and then they're hearing
from their product manager that hey
i need you to push this thing uh in a
day and then we're saying no do it
in certain way at that point we're not
being empathetic to their
their deadlines and the pressures that
they're feeling from business at that
point
we want to understand and make sure that
they're delivering the value
and they're getting the most out of the
whole thing and not just pushing our
agenda forward
and then once we start developing this
understanding we're just peers
and not um not somebody that is sitting
over there in architecture we're just
we are your peers we are just fellow
engineers we are
we're similar to tech leads at that
point once you establish that
that kind of confidence with with the
teams
uh the need for um that kind of review
kind of tapers off
and the team leads at that point kind of
knew
what i was going to say and because we
established that understanding with each
other
and that we need for the review kind of
tapered off over a period of time which
was the benefit of this
refactoring then the question becomes
when to review
the are you going to come in towards the
end of the process and then
review think about amazon um so when
they were
building let's say the checkout process
and then if they wanted to
when they wanted to make the cqrs type
of process where
when you buy or buy buy an item on
amazon
um you're not sitting there and watching
them ship the order and things like that
they say okay we'll get back to you
but that kind of experience was not
developed just by the ip folks they
partner with the business folks as well
so that they can come to that uh
understanding together make the system
scalable
but they have to work together on that
so you have to be involved right from
the beginning right from the user
experience
side of things when you're making these
important decisions about things
when you're building frameworks when
you're creating new services what is
your event
structure things like that so while when
i was part of these
um meetings i was able to tell the
people that they needed certain
information
the existing events were out there and
they had stories
in their backlog saying oh we need to
generate these events
and they were able to just remove those
stories because they
because i was able to tell them that hey
those events exist and you don't have to
worry about that and that saved them
time so from that standpoint
when you're trying to make these
important decisions if you involve
somebody
that is looking at the entire picture of
the jungle instead of one tree
they'll be able to help you and that's
what architecture team does and that's
when
the review should happen where um when
you're making these important decisions
and if we do it as a peer then this
review is more of like hey just double
check me please instead of like trying
to somebody just troll you at that point
that brings me to the next point which
is working culture
what is going on in this picture here
we have four people locked up in a room
uh they're working on something
and at that point everybody hourly
uh spend the company that's spending um
paying them and there's they're spending
money
um on this meeting a lot of money and
you know that that money
basically is uh tied up in the
output of what these guys are going to
do so if if nothing productive happens
in this meeting that money is basically
wasted
um code 19 has changed some of this
now we're doing all of this stuff in
zoom and webex or whatever
but still the synchronous nature of
these kind of meetings
is very difficult to kind of like
keep it becomes very difficult to keep
things
efficient
why is that because world just doesn't
work synchronously if you look at
if you look at your fast food
restaurants or anything they're not
once you put in the order um they're not
asking you to wait uh in order for
the next order to come in
they're just sir they're saying yes we
will
we will serve you but um you go over
uh over there and then the next person
can pay
um and bring and and take their order
so that they're taking orders as much as
possible and asynchronously serving
everybody when the
the when these things are ready so we're
taking this example
uh from the fast food restaurants but
then
if you look at the i mean so that's how
the world works
when we're talking about efficiency but
when we start locking ourselves into
these meetings
and workshops and constant data
conversations uh it becomes very
inefficient
and we started seeing that our calendars
are always busy um
and everybody's trying to talk to each
other all the time and then you become
scattered brain because
you're trying to do all these things and
you're working on the last problem that
you heard
so we started looking at how can we
solve this problem
and here's an example of automapper
the open source library and that's what
we wanted to take an inspiration from
um there are thousands of issues solved
hundred-plus contributors
not many open issues millions of
downloads how this is
how this is working um
so from that standpoint they don't have
meetings uh they don't have
gear channels or they're not they're not
talking to each other all the time
they're not
setting uh meetings to have like oh
where is this going to
go in the future things of that nature
what they have is decent documentation
that's developed
collaboratively and we want to take
ideas from
this kind of structure so what is the
what is it that working for them it's
it's about communication
um they're publicizing their
architecture vision uh where they want
to go
um and then it's repeated on different
different forms that's what we wanted to
uh that's what we wanted to do um
throughout our company so that people
have the understanding and
really push for asynchrony as much as
possible and this is where the
documentation also helps
so when you're sending when you're
setting up an email and meaning that
when you're setting up and when you're
setting up a meeting and at that point
when you send a documentation to
somebody saying hey just review this
before the meeting
um your meeting may just get cancelled
they say hey the documentation looks
good
um i i don't have any questions and or
they may say okay i agree with 90
of it just talk about let's talk about
the 10 percent i don't understand
and have a conversation at that point an
hour meeting could be just 10 minutes
so really really start pushing for that
asynchronous nature of things
build the accountability make sure that
you're delivering
um delivering the a product or on
written
on on time and produce screencast
presentation newsletters
uh things that are nature so you're
repeating what what
what the vision is all about and then
what we're trying to do here really here
is that we're trying to be the change
that we believe in instead of
just saying we are the architecture uh
we want we want to push
certain things certain way we are really
trying to
incorporate that change in ourselves so
that we are being the leader of the
company
and one of the things that we also
started looking at was having
a development team while you're for the
architectural work as well
so that a team of volunteers can work on
the tasks that are building
frameworks that are looking at different
things so that you don't
the architects if they're involved in
certain high level aspects
at that point they may not have the time
to come back and code
and they can switch that position back
and forth with other team members at
that point
so that everybody's coding as well as
trying to keep their eye
on the big big picture so these
rotational volunteers
can do the development team and that's
what we thought that was
that could help from the working culture
standpoint and empathy is really
important because
we wanted to understand that we we
understand the deadlines we wanted to
understand people's motives
when we didn't want to become a blocker
we don't want to become we didn't want
to become another red tape that they had
to
go through we want to make sure that we
are helping them
meet their deadlines not become the
deadline or not become a blocker
so with that this is what the talks
about hey this is what you came here for
the role of architects
what is what is it that you're trying
you're supposed to do from marketing
standpoint
so the confusion was still there um
about the
role and the vision and things that we
talked about
what are you supposed to do as an
architect are you supposed to just code
are you a tech lead are you drawing some
pretty pictures are you doing the
documentation for somebody
are you doing a maintenance brick
project are you working with
are you working with it organization rt
part of things or
ops part of things are you working with
business what are you supposed to do
so first and foremost um you're you're
you're going to code
so the refactoring that we applied here
was that
non-coding architects don't exist and we
want to make sure of that
and then you're the reason why behind
your coding is that you're
sort of like trail basing uh if you can
and extracting pattern uh off
some existing core that that could be
out there um
and then kind of like building out the
framework for future
for for the teams to follow afterwards
um so you should be coding as an
architect
is something that we started working um
very deliberately on
and that's the kind of thing that helped
us from the dev team that we just
we just saw earlier that architecture
team used to have
that you can switch back and forth but
somebody spent a time
doing just high level work for last one
month it's been a long time since
decoded
yes we need to get them back into the
recording team standpoint and start
have them kind of like get their hands
dirty a little bit more
and then they can go back into the high
level work if they're helping out on the
teams from that perspective
so then going back to this definition
again uh we wanted to
do the coding work so that we are trying
to
set the patterns and so that the teams
don't have to
um exercise creativity every time
they're trying to
solve a problem and the coding part
has kind of like the other side of it
which is laying out laying down the
groundwork but how do we do that how do
we teach people
uh when we are done with solving the
problem or things like that so pairing
is a great way of doing it
um if there is something that you're
expert in
some people are expert at react back-end
work
events whatever it could be so at that
point if you're working with
somebody who is not experienced in that
world you can help them out by appearing
that's how i learned lots of different
things by pairing with more experienced
people at the time
and resharper shortcuts is one of the
examples that has stuck with me for
over the years that i didn't know what i
was doing when i was
working with resharper a few years like
i would say seven eight years ago
and at that point i worked with a very
smart engineer he showed me how to use
these
shortcuts effectively and kind of not
break your chain of thought
and that helped me a lot immensely so
that was that's why i love
that since then i kind of fell in love
with pairing but then
it could be really draining if you're
working if you're if you're appearing
all the time
and if you're an introvert it could be
even more draining so
you want to pick and choose on how many
problems that you're going to work on as
fair
but definitely pairing is a great great
way of getting your hands dirty
and helping the team out from core
standpoint
the high level picture is also important
you don't want to lose sight of the
entire
the big picture side of things you don't
want to lose sight of the
the jungle how it looks like if you're
working on a particular tree or
how the tree fits into the large large
world um
things things that are nature is very
important from the big picture side of
things you want to make sure if you're
building a bus
um when the individual parts are being
developed
you're actually coming to that um you're
actually going you're on the path of
building that bus
and not not something else that brings
us to the
strong opinions loosely held type of
thing so most of the architects
on our team were experienced and
everybody was very strong willed and
strong opinion
at that point when you have that it
could become sometimes contentious
and the meetings could become a little
more opinionated
and whose opinion's right at that point
so
it could so if we establish this kind of
refactoring kind of like motto
uh my strong opinions should be loosely
held
what that's really means is yes you are
allowed to have your opinions when but
when the data
comes up that tells you otherwise you
should be willing to adapt
and that sets the example so instead of
saying i'm the right and i'm the
authority
i'm saying yes i have some opinions but
if the data shows me that oh i should
kind of make a compromise to my opinions
and go different way yes i should be
doing that and when you do that you are
being the change that you believe in i
don't know who actually said this
um it's a disputed code this somebody's
said it i really like it um i don't know
who the author is
that part is disputed i really like the
uh
kind of like owning the change that you
want to see
everywhere as a leader and you're
at that point you're doing you're doing
things as you're asking other people to
do when you say oh you need to have
effective diagrams
into your documentation okay show them
your diagram and
see what that effective diagram could be
instead of just saying
no you should be doing that no let's
work together or
show them your work so that they know
that you have been there
um and then you're solving problems as
as much as you're helping them solve a
problem at that point you gain
some credibility when you're working
with these teams
then one example
that we had over here was about events
so one team was struggling with what the
body of the event what the property
should be of our event going forward and
there was a lot of
a lot of conversation happening around
that so from that standpoint
um when what we
kind of like started settling on is that
hey can we just create
id and timestamp and just give some name
to it because we can always come back
and add properties as we see more
information going forward so
what we're trying to do here is that
we're trying to help
people deliver their values quickly as
possible instead of being stuck
on certain things instead of being stuck
on trivia
we're saying you know just put an id in
timestamp and move on
have the event see how that looks like
put it into production
and then you can build the properties
over time and then
we did we have done that in past like
i've
shared my code with the teams and then
at that point they were able to see
how the whole process looked like and
then how the event kind of
got built over time and then we created
new events based on the new information
that came up
things of that nature so we're showing
them
as we did things instead of just saying
oh you should be doing certain things
um nothing turns off people they then
unnecessary pushing off vendors tools
whatever your favorite thing could be if
you if you don't
if you if you don't have clear
definition around the problem
oh um you're using you're using
a particular tool and that's what you
like but then the other team's using
something else let's say you like
rabbitmq but then the
other teams using azure service bus um
why does it matter as long as they have
some transport in place
it doesn't matter what kind of tool
that's in place
as long as the problem is being solved
so don't try to be
pushy as far as the tooling and vendors
and
all of that are everything around that
and we also wanted to establish that um
architects are not
managers they can help team members
become the next leaders but they're not
going gonna
get involved in organizational work
they're not gonna go approve somebody's
time off or anything like that but
they're gonna help
they're gonna be more of mentors but not
managers
um playing to the strength of
architects and i have my own
interests and over the time that i have
built
uh some understanding about those
concepts and i like to work in them such
as events messaging
microservices distributed system side of
things from the backing standpoint
they could be other so we had other team
members who were experts in front and
side of things
so whenever we had issues that were in
each other's realms we would involve
each other
and take advice accordingly instead of
trying to learn something that you were
not
doing for last couple of years if you
haven't worked on something for the last
couple of years
at that point you can say very easily
that you're not an expert in that
so accept that and then move forward
instead of trying to
learn all the skills that are out there
don't try to be jack of all and don't
try to force that onto your teams
and that's the kind of thing that we
started implementing internally in the
architecture teams that we're trying to
play to our strengths
instead of trying to fit um instead of
trying to fit into all kinds of roles
that are that are out there
so if you forgot about everything um up
to this point
what is the role of architect
refactoring look like so you're kind of
fitting into these three words you're
coding you're doing high level work and
then you're making sure
that you're delivering value to your
business that's what architects should
be doing
so if you think about the bus analogy
that we just mentioned we
we talked about earlier uh that
architecture is making sure
that you're actually delivering the bus
which is the business need
and then they're kind of like when the
wheel is being developed when the
steering is being developed and the
engines being developed
all of that stuff like how that stuff
comes together is what architecture is
all about
and what the architecture should be
keeping track of but hey when these
little things that are developed they're
kind of going in
in the in the right direction if they
can apply some
efficiencies along the way in those
little tasks that are happening
uh yes that makes sense but then they
you want
you wanna as an architect you wanna make
sure that the
the business value is getting delivered
from the entire project
and that's what you should be doing then
the question becomes who should become
an architect
um should excellent engineers like the
really experienced engineers should
become architects
are problem servers great communicators
um
who should really be an architect so
when i was junior developer like i
always thought that oh
next step in my career could be senior
dev and one day
um if i keep doing the good work that
one day i'll become
become an architect but uh that skill
architect skill is different than um
being an engineer or anything similar to
that because
you could have an excellent engineer but
they could not be a good architect
so it's not everybody's it's not a
natural
next step of um you know in your career
so if you're an excellent engineer
uh you don't necessarily have to become
an architect to hit that next step
so you're excellent engineer you're an
excellent engineer that's that's it
if you have interest in architecture yes
you should become an architect
uh but then you should kind of like um
you there's no it's not a next step in
your career you could be junior
architect and still do really well
so the qualities that i have seen in
really good architects
are um they can teach with empathy they
have good variety of experience
and typically around different kinds of
tools and different working cultures
they are really good at communicating
and and giving feedback to the teams
instead of
saying oh this is what you're doing
wrong because if you come from that side
of side of things then
people kind of shut you down um so
instead they help you get towards the
right thing
instead of telling you what you're doing
wrong and that's the kind of
communication skills that
these successful architects tend to have
they're not shying away from getting
their hands dirty
um so if whether it comes to talking to
business whether it's coding or where
whatever it is they're willing to solve
a problem
and in in any shape or form they can
help
they are going to do that and that's the
kind of and then
able to handle uncertain scenarios so
this is very crucial when it comes to
architecture
because you're trying to solve a
business problem that was not
solved before or things of that nature
so things could get really uncertain so
you may have to build a consensus with
business
with infrastructure teams that whatever
you may have
and sometimes people are not just
comfortable with that and that's totally
fine
uh you if you're not comfortable
handling that kind of uncertainty
uh it is totally fine you're you you can
be the expert of your art instead of
trying to
force yourself into this architect role
so do not consider
architect as a next step in your career
instead it's just another
kind of an engineer that you have on
your team
and these architects tend to be
pragmatic in um
strong opinions loosely held and when
data shows to me
that hey there is something that's
that's incorrect
or um when the data shows
you know i should be thinking about
something else yes i should be willing
to make that change
and that's what these pragmatic
architectures have done over the years
so um parting thoughts so what does this
thing have to do with microservices
at all um so microservices are about
autonomy
there's a spiderman coating there what
does this have to do
with microservices and what happened
here so
when you don't have architecture when
you don't have a strong team of
architects
trying to help you out with
microservices transformation uh
and you take on this kind of a journey
that can bring in a lot of churn
and it can become really expensive
exercise
without that directional guidance and
that's what we saw from microservices
standpoint
but hey when you're trying to take on a
transformation exercise
from your legacy applications to
microservices or
going to the cloud things of that nature
when you're transforming
your organization at that point you need
to have this team
in place and we kind of learned that
lesson the hard way
so what's the takeaway here um the
architecture is about
intentional direction and
that's the why of architecture we want
to set that intentional directions it's
about the important decisions
and that's the one how we do that we
code
um we make sure that we have diagrams we
are mentoring team we're bringing people
on board
onto the team so that they can
understand the systems
we're bringing them with us um when
should you do
the architecture asynchronously when the
important decisions are made
and really architecture is for people to
understand your system it's not for
um the kinds of a business architecture
that we're talking about they're not
we any picture or any documentation that
you're writing
you're not giving that to a computer
system and then that's generating code
and that's getting deployed
it's for people to understand so
audience for your architecture is
usually people
so you want to keep in mind when you're
building architecture and then who
should become architect
the mentors the people who regularly
codes they're leaders they're they're
the change that they believe in
they're owning the change they're very
result oriented they're not
um shying away from getting their hands
dirty whether it's
when it comes to talking to business or
writing the code and
of course they have strong opinions but
they're weakly held
and if you forgot about the whole thing
um
and if you want to take away one thing
from this this is what i want you to
take
from the architect's standpoint that
you're coding
you're also taking keeping an eye on
high level stuff
and you're setting the patterns so that
people can follow afterwards and then
you're solving the business problems and
this is
what i would like to take uh if if
there's one thing that i want to take
from this presentation
so with that we have a few minutes left
for questions and this is way that you
can contact me that's my blog
twitter handle and that's my github
so let's see if i have
questions